welcome to the graveyard please keep
your voices down it's a very somber
place you can feel the sadness here the
pain the things left unsaid in that
sense it's not unlike every other
graveyard all across the world but of
course we wouldn't be covering it here
if it wasn't just any graveyard would we
the eagle-eyed among you may notice that
we're walking through a military
cemetery for starters but the people
buried here aren't the martyrs of any
war your history teacher would tell you
about the people and entities entered
here fought their wars in the shadows
they died in the dark so we could live
in the light but who are they what is
this place who are the people buried
here really to find that out we need to
take a step back it began in site 43
specifically laboratory 37 of site 43's
artificial intelligence wing researchers
were conducting a series of tests on a
few classified artificial intelligence
anomalies with the help of a
foundation-made artificial intelligence
construct known as marvin however what
was meant to be a set of routine
cognition tests turned into a mass
containment breach believed to be
coordinated by several of the rogue ais
involved things went sideways quickly
the breach resulted in the deaths of
three members of security personnel and
it was only stopped when marvin and a
more benevolent anomaly worked together
to get things back under control while
their efforts were valiant they weren't
enough to save marvin himself who was
rendered inoperable during the breach
all of the copies of the anomalous ais
were neutralized after testing was
complete under the orders of the site
director the remaining materials
relating to marvin and the neutralized
anomalies were left in laboratory 37
things appeared to be returning to
normal until maintenance personnel
entered the lab later that day you can
undeniably encounter some pretty strange
things inside an scp foundation
laboratory it comes with the territory
but when you walk into a lab and find
yourself standing in a giant military
cemetery it's probably time to contact
your supervisors and let them know while
those maintenance workers didn't truly
comprehend what they discovered the
foundation researchers who got involved
shortly afterward were able to take in
the full scope of it an ever-expanding
extra-dimensional graveyard seeming to
exist outside of space and time as we
understand it which soon became known to
the foundation as scp-2783
the cemetery is believed to currently
contain over a million graves that's
over double the mere 400 000 buried at
arlington national cemetery these graves
are meticulously arranged into huge
square grids each one containing around
90 000 graves apiece this would be
peculiar enough in its own right but
things got a whole lot stranger each
grave is clearly marked with a name and
an epitaph but ground penetrating radar
tests conducted by the foundation
revealed that only 30 of the graves
actually contain human remains and the
remaining 70 are currently empty and
considering that the number of graves
actually seems to be increasing at an
arbitrary rate it isn't difficult to
draw the conclusion that some event in
the near future is destined to fill
these empty graves perhaps a war like
one we've never seen is on the horizon
and
scp-2783 is growing in preparation to
house its teeming casualties death is a
funny thing it can have varied and
unpredictable faces in the eyes of its
beholders and the great
scp-2783 cemetery is no exception to
this rule it appears slightly different
to all who view it even when viewing it
at the same time
factors like climate and weather are
dictated by the place of a person's
origin the same goes for the style of
the grave markers they seem to be
culturally specific to the beholder's
view of what a military grave marker
tends to look like and the epitaphs are
written in the native language of
whoever sees them it is a truly
universal cemetery a place where anyone
and everyone can come and grieve the
courageous fallen with equal
understanding and respect the foundation
has been able to use gps tracking to
locate the graveyard's equivalent on our
planet tracing it back to an ancient
tomb in southern iraq there the
foundation collaborated with the oria
the organization for the reclamation of
islamic artifacts to investigate further
the mission discovered a number of
artifacts belonging to several
previously undocumented pre-mesopotamian
civilizations but failed to uncover any
physical evidence of scp-2783
at this site the cemetery is marked off
by a fence that seems impossible to
penetrate those who walk through the
door in laboratory 37 manifest just
outside of a gate built into the fence
however any attempt to walk back through
this gate will simply lead to the
subject exiting back through the doors
to laboratory 37. thankfully for any
foundation staff who left something they
actually needed in laboratory 37 the
teleportation does not affect machines
so remote controlled robots can still be
sent into the lab shortly after
discovering scp-2783
reconnaissance teams were sent in to
start cataloging the grave markings as
concerning information started to pour
in the foundation upped the security
clearance on both physical and
informational access to scp-2783
nobody below level 5 security clearance
is able to see the full picture so
what is the full picture well at the
risk of getting assassinated by the red
right hand let's take a look at a few
recorded grave markers and see if we can
find out take grave double a0000
inscribed with the name yhwh
a potential shortening of the name
yahweh a common alias of the abrahamic
god the epitaph on the grade reads he
was vital in her construction his design
shall prove vital in her reconstruction
however there are multiple variants of
this grave and while all seem to
memorialize some kind of creator deity
there seems to be no favoritism of any
particular type of deity or any specific
religious denomination
sightings of variants of this gravestone
have reached the double digits then
there's grave double a0002
marked hawa bat
also known as eve the first woman her
grave marking reads the serpent within
the library bestowed upon her great
wisdom her loss inspires us all to seek
wisdom in this the living world it is
believed by some that ashrae was the
mother of cain and abel
scp-073 and scp-076
and also spent a period of time as 05-1
wishing to guide humanity in the right
direction how about grave double a0005
marked lilitbot yhwh
also known as
scp-336 her epitaph reads she was loved
greatly her beauty will not be forgotten
according to foundation records lilith
is a beautiful humanoid woman with
reptilian legs whose enchanting voice
has the power to induce infertility in
women and a combination of comas and
anomalous tumors in men anomalous in the
sense that they will birth vicious
deadly chimeras next grave double a0006
marked set ben adam his epitaph reads
this graveyard was constructed under his
orders when those interred here rise
again it is under his command they shall
fight seth or seth is also known as
scp-4840-a
a powerful sibling of cain and abel
living in
scp-4840 how when or why he decided to
order the construction of scp-2783
is unknown then grave ab21917
marked unknown their epitaph reads a
crafter of the flesh and a disciple of
the tongueless speaker a worthy foe his
precious moments were expended on the
hordes of the crimson crown and so he is
memorialized among the heroes of the
people radars of the grave showed that
the creature interred with had the
biology atypical of a human our
interpretation of the epitaph is that
this was a follower of sarkicism the
worship of the flesh who worked with the
church of the broken god and the scp
foundation to fight against the scarlet
king and died a hero as a result next
grave
al21343 believed to belong to dr sophia
light her epitaph reads our savior and
prophet our staff and shepherd the
machine goddess smiled upon this house
and even now those who rest here are
tended to this is one of the many
references to the machine or clockwork
goddess an alternate title from meccan
the deity of the church of the broken
god evidence suggests that this cemetery
was the work of the church and that all
who are entered there were or are going
to be aligned with the broken god in the
struggle against a far greater threat to
us all next al-30056
marked nicholas flamel with the epitaph
an esteemed scholar who rose to great
heights but like icarus fell from great
heights while mythologically flamel is
believed to have been an alchemist and
creator of the legendary philosopher's
stone the foundation hasn't detected any
confirmed anomalous activity connected
to him of much greater interest to fans
of this channel we come upon al41867
marked lord theodore thomas blackwood
his epitaph reading his service to the
advancement of science and humanity
shall carry on a full-sized human
skeleton lays in the grave so perhaps
lord blackwood's service did carry on
just in a different body then came the
grave of private pyotr after whose
epitaph reads he and his fellows have
seen the gates of hell though they do
not deserve it they shall be first to
greet the hordes of the crimson crown
when the gates open fans of this channel
may remember private aftooka from our
coverage of scp-180
he was one of the soldiers involved in
the horrific ordeal of the anomalous
battle of houstian woods another name
you might recognize is the one carved
into gravemarker am21450
dr alto clef that's right everyone's
favorite lovable loose cannon his
epitaph reads a loving father he gave
much more than was demanded of him the
variants of his grave also lists his
other aliases agent ukulele and adam l
assem the first man the date of his
death corresponds with a recorded near
containment breach that resulted in the
deaths of two other members of personnel
cleft cheats death another day
for now and the most recent grave am
21488 was the grave of marvin the aic
that helped save the day during the
containment breach that opened the
portal to scp-2783
his epitaph reads a machine mind that
gave his life to protect his builders
just as the machine got us before him
there will always be a place in paradise
for those who gave of themselves as he
did it is somewhat heartwarming to know
that in the eyes of the clockwork
goddess a mere ai can be revered just as
much for heroism as anyone constructed
from flesh and blood recorded back in
2017 during a routine search agent
philip mclean saw 13 humanoid entities
in funeral car with an insignia
described as a white circular shield
with three equidistant protrusions
inside the shield were three equidistant
black arrows piercing a white circle
outlined in black these entities
performed what seemed to be funeral
rites before committing another body to
the dirt below the name on the new grave
marker was captain karim michelle hollis
mobile task force zeta9 her epitaph read
she died in the strange and far away
place with a smile on her face a weapon
in her hand and foes on all sides she
exemplified what all warriors should
strive to be for those of you that can
remember our three-part series on
scp-1730
you may also remember that captain
hollis was the brave mtf leader who
sacrificed her own life in the terrible
bowels of site 13 to turn on the
thresher machine kicking the whole awful
place to another dimension here her
heroic sacrifice can never be forgotten
while there's an ominous subtext to a
lot of scp-2783
from its predictions of individual
deaths to hints at a bloody war with the
scarlet king coming down the tracks
there's something undeniably beautiful
about the idea of this place we share in
the morning and reverence of the
clockwork goddess of heroes great and
small gone but never forgotten in
scp-2783
no act of courage or sacrifice will ever
be lost to time be sure to leave quietly
on your way out like we said before this
is a somber place now go check out
scp-1440 the old man that kills all
living things he touches an evil monster
created by scp foundation
scp-2419 the laughing men for more scps
linked to death the final frontier